how did the birds and the bees talko
with your son so good yeah nailed it I
think I nailed it pretty sure I nailed
it did you have to have like a formal I
I had a I had a a uh I did have a talk I
did uh with him I feel like it was this
exact energy I did um no eye contact was
made I looked down out of the ceiling
floor and then when I'd finish the
statement I go we good and then I was
out we're cool homie
uh no all but uh his generation is
obviously much different than mine I all
I said was you know obviously uh if you
have any questions box uh under uh the
car we don't use in the garage please
take a look take your
time lock the door your mother won't be
home till late get in and out leave
everything as you found it give yourself
about a 15minute cush trust me on that
one oh God